Speaker 1: Also in New Hampshire was not only
Ron DeSantis, but it was also Donald Trump in
New Hampshire. Trump gave a speech which we will
look at, but I don't remember if this was before
or after the speech. Donald Trump was confronted
about the leaked crime tape. Now, I don't even
know that we should call it a leaked audio tape.
It's a leaked crime tape in which Trump confirms,
yeah, he knew the documents were classified.
He knew he didn't declassify them. He knew he
was no longer the president. And he still showed
them to people. It is evidence of Trump's crimes
and it is not vaguely of Trump's crimes. He might
be charged with It's evidence of Trump's crimes
that he has already been charged with and indicted
for. Trump is asked about the leaked audio tape,
and he says, Honestly, I don't even know how
to explain what he says. He just basically
malfunctions here and says, I did nothing wrong.
Speaker 5: We did absolutely nothing wrong. This
is just another hoax. It's called, I would
say, election interference more than anything
else. It's a disgrace that they can do it.
Next question. But everything was fine. We
did nothing wrong and everybody knows it.
Speaker 4: Here's a sample of that newly
released audio from two years ago.
Speaker 5: I was just saying because
we're talking about an era, he
said. He wanted to attack Iran and.
Speaker 2: Now he's said the press.
Speaker 5: Yes, you don't the military given
to me. I think we can. And there will be very.
Speaker 4: Yet last week with our colleague
Bret Baer, the former president
insisted that document did not exist.
Speaker 5: There was no document that was a
massive amount of papers and everything else
talking about Iran and other things. And it may
have been held up or made up, but that was not
a document. I didn't have a document per se.
Speaker 1: It wasn't a document per se. So,
listen, that's Fox News. First of all, notable
that even Fox News now they realize that it is
an incoherent string of lies that conflict
with each other. He says to Bret BAIER,
there were no documents in the recording. He
says. Here's documents. Then he says it was
fine to show the documents, but because I could
declassify them. But in the recording, he says,
they clearly weren't. You know, it's it's all a
mess. And Trump's brain seems to be functioning
so poorly that he's lost an understanding of what
words even mean at this point. What is hoax mean
at this point? And what what does it mean that it
is a hoax? There is a an audio recording. Is he
saying it's doctored? Is he saying the words he
uses in the video no longer have meaning? And of
course, if you just sit back and think about all
of the conflicting things that have been said,
you start to wonder, listen, don't you understand,
guys? The tape is a hoax. He had the documents,
but he had the right to because he declassified
them. Except he says on the recording he didn't
declassify them, but the documents were planted
and it's not a crime anyway. And also there were
no documents. Why won't you just accept that?
Why is it you will just insist on going after
this guy, the biggest victim in the world,
the most honest man in political history?
Why won't you accept the seven different
conflicting explanations about what he did,
what he had, and what he said? And if you think
that this moment when he was interviewed before
or after the speech was bad, you have
to see the actual speech that he gave